governor andrew cuomo continuing to
embarrass himself with comments like
this about covid
we were ambushed like no other state
nicole
and again it was from federal
incompetence
incompetent government kills people
incompetent government kills people more
people
died than needed to die in covet
that's the truth
that's pretty rich given cuomo's
disastrous handling of the pandemic
here's what the governor won't tell you
new york ranks second
among all states and kova deaths per 100
000 people
remember his coronavirus nursing home
policy that killed over 8
000 people well now cuomo is refusing to
release new numbers about the total
number of deaths
and then there's the fact that people
are fleeing his state in droves
more people left new york than any other
state according to census data
and thanks to cuomo's lockdowns his
state lost
a million jobs during the pandemic and
cuomo doesn't expect those jobs to come
back
until 2025. wow greg that was rich
wasn't it
yeah i mean you know life events create
great leaders
and cuomo not a great leader a simple
comparison in the pandemic
lover hate him trump ushered in two
vaccines in world record time
in the pandemic cuomo wrote a book
he wrote a book and got an emmy and got
an emmy that's right
and and did a comedy act on cnn um but i
think that the most idiotic
uh example is that while this pandemic
is killing thousands of people a day
our nation's leaders are pursuing the
impeachment of someone
who is already out of office they are
seeking removal of someone who is not in
office instead of trying to save lives
don't tell me they can do both at the
same time because they know
they can't because so far they have
delayed many things out of politics
including the relief package not once
but twice
and also with the hearings on the
pandemic last year they ignored that
in favor of impeachment so people died
because they just want to get back at
the orange monster
katie all you need to know about how bad
andrew cuomo is as a governor and as a
so-called leader on this
is that bill de blasio the mayor of new
york city looks competent compared to
andrew cuomo
juan i mean will he admit anything that
he did was wrong or was it just perfect
no i think i think everybody thinks that
what happened with the nursing homes
it was tragic and you know families lost
loved ones jesse
he did it intentionally i mean he wanted
to clear space at hospitals but it was
an
error but to my mind i think you have to
even with the nursing home deaths look
at the stats and what the stats will
show is
yes new york is second in those deaths
that you put up on the screen
but remember most of those deaths the
overwhelming number
took place in march and april of last
year when coronavirus was just hitting
the united states and overwhelming new
york
and from the federal government there
was no really
effective response at that juncture
that's when president trump was saying
oh
it's a hoax you know it'll be gone in a
few days you know
that's what he was saying he never
called it now you look at it
okay and now you look at it jesse and it
seems to me
you know you have to take into account
new york is a global capital people
flying from all over the world they
bring everything in
right now new york is among the lowest
the lowest in the nation in terms of
infection rates it's not
it's still well then on average but it
was even lower
why can't we eat inside dana
everything's great
i think there's you know there's a light
at the end of the tunnel on that that
looks like it's going to come back
sooner
than later which is really welcome uh
believe me um peter's been cooking but
you know we gotta get back out there
um the other difference between uh trump
and cuomo
is when cuomo says you know and i don't
think these jobs are coming back for
until 2025
that's what they thought in terms of the
vaccine yep um president trump would say
we're going to get these jobs back and
we're going to cut regulations and we're
going to do this we're going to cut
taxes and everyone's
and even if it didn't come to full
fruition there would be somebody that
said
we got this we're going to lead instead
of just saying i'm going to blame the
federal government for these errors
yeah if you're really cheerleading for
your own state you don't just say yeah
they'll never be back right